[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit Heinz
Wolf und Marietta slomker guten Abend
als grand old Party wird die Partei der
Republikaner in den USA auch bezeichnet
diesen ehrwürd Namen verdiente sie sich
in den Zeiten des Bürgerkriegs im 19
Jahrhundert die Republikaner waren die
Partei Abraham Lincolns eine Partei der
Liberalen die die Sklaverei abschafften
im 20 Jahrhundert wandelte sie sich zu
einem konservativen Partei konservativ
und
staatstragend was ist aus diesen
Republikanern geworden sie lieen sich
von Donald Trump Kern sie haben sich bis
heute nicht wirklich vom Putschversuch
des 6 Januar 2021 distanziert und jetzt
haben die radikalsten in ihren Reihen
das amerikanische Parlament zu einem
chaosclub degradiert mit absichtsvoll
zerstörerischer Wirkung und folgen die
weit über die USA
hinausgehen Claudia Bates berichtet aus
Washington mit einem wütenden
Hammerschlag für die Geschichtsbücher
ist die Sache besiegelt Kevin mcary der
Sprecher des Repräsentantenhauses
abgesetzt Kennedy sagte einst wer in
seinem Streben nach Macht töricht auf
dem Rücken des Tigers reiten wolle der
werde in seinem Bauch Enden mccathi
hatte sich auf Deals mit den radikalsten
Kräften der Republikaner eingelassen
dafür verhalfen sie ihm zur Macht und
trieben ihn erbarmungslos vor sich her
als er jetzt ernsthafte Politik machen
wollte um das Land gemeinsam mit den
Demokraten vorm verheerenden schatdown
einer Zahlungsunfähigkeit zu bewahren
hat der Tiger ihn gefressen die
radikalen haben ihm die Unterstützung
entzogen sie können nicht behaupten sie
seinen konservativ weil sie wütend sind
und chaotisch das ist nicht meine Partei
in der Partei von Ronald Reagan hat man
daran geglaubt dass man mit Prinzipien
konservativ regieren kann die sind nicht
konservativ und haben kein Recht auf
diesen
Titel der republikanische Hardliner matt
Gates hat die interne Revolte angeführt
hat Chaos gestiftet er wollte den
regierungsstillstand wollte dem stat den
Hahn abdrehen einen Kompromiss lehnte er
in enger Abstimmung mit Ex-Präsident
Trump ab
Fundamentalopposition jetzt genießt er
das Scheinwerferlicht und wettert gegen
seine Marionette die sich selbstständig
gemacht
hat wenn die Demokraten Kevin McCarthy
besitzen wollen können Sie ihn haben mit
einer Sache bin ich völlig im reinen
wenn wir in einer Woche wieder hier
stehen dann will ich Kevin McCarthy
nicht mehr haben zu mir gehört er dann
nicht mehr die Demokraten kön
adoptieren die Republikaner kämpfen um
ihre Identität ihre Mehrheit im
Repräsentantenhaus ist knapp so haben
wenige viel Macht und lähmen den Rest
der
Partei das ist eine Politik des
Kannibalismus sie fressen die eigenen
Leute die Republikaner haben vor langem
in den frühen 90ern entschieden dass sie
eine verrückte Politik machen können und
damit immer wieder zum Sieg reiten
können aber mit Trump hat das sie sehr
stark eingeholt
nach der Abwahl des mächtigen Sprechers
steht im Kongress jetzt erstmal alles
still und das wenige Wochen vor einer
wieder drohenden Haushaltssperre das
Parlament müsste auch über neue Hilfen
für die Ukraine
entscheiden die Vorstellung dass im
Kongress der USA Leute sind die mehr
daran interessiert sind Wladimir Putin
zu helfen als die Demokratie zu
verteidigen das kriege ich nicht in
meinen
Kopf Präsident Biden gibt sich
zuversichtlich dass die USA weiterhin
die versprochenen Hilfen leisten werden
gefragt ob er einen Rat hat für den
nächsten Sprecher des
Repräsentantenhauses erst ein Lachen
dann das ist über meiner
Gehaltsklasse tatsächlich ist völlig
unklar wie es im Kongress nun
weitergehen
soll tja fragen wir unseren
Korrespondenten in Washington Elma
teveson Elma um das Ganze erstmal
grundsätzlich einzuschätzen wie
erheblich wie dramatisch ist
das also das ist erheblich es hat's eben
in der Geschichte so noch nie gegeben es
gab versuche den Sprecher zu stürzen in
der Vergangenheit diesmal ist es
erstmalig gelungen und das eben mit
Hilfe einer ganz kleinen Gruppe von
radikalen Extremisten innerhalb einer
Partei und das zeigt im Grunde genommen
dass die republikanische Partei so
zerstritten ist dass hier Fragezeichen
aufkommen ob sie überhaupt in der Lage
ist regierungsfähig zu sein und das
sorgt dafür dass hier momentan im
Repräsentanten aus nichts passiert also
keine Gesetzesvorhaben keine
ausschussanhörung das heißt nichts von
der Agenda der Republikaner und
natürlich auch nichts von der Agenda der
Demokraten kann durchgesetzt werden aber
irgendwie muss es ja weitergehen wie wie
kann es
weitergehen ja nun versucht man
natürlich fieberhaft jemand Neues zu
finden nächste Woche Dienstag will man
sich treffen und schauen ob man einen
Kandidaten findet hinterdem man sich
versammelt am Mittwoch nächster Woche
soll dann gewählt werden wenn man denn
einen findet den wenn man einen von den
radikalen neähme dann findet der mit
Sicherheit keine Unterstützung bei allen
anderen und die sind ja eigentlich
darauf angewiesen auf jede Stimme in
ihrer eigenen Fraktion zu bekommen viele
hier sind stinksauer darauf dass mccafi
gestürzt worden ist und wenn man einen
näme der eher Moderator ist dann wäre er
ja am Ende auch abhängig von den Stimmen
dieser radikalen würde gewissermaßen
Marionette oder Geisel sein müssen so
wie John Kennedy wir haben es vorhin
gehört dass die Tat ja mal gesagt wird
gesagt hat dass am Ende wenn man sich
auf den Tiger setzt um an die Macht zu
kommen man dann von diesem auch
gefressen wird mhm und ist dieser
tigerritz nicht nur für die USA vertal
sondern in ganz besonderer Form auch für
die Ukraine und da geht's ja nicht nur
um Waffenlieferung die USA waren bisher
auch der größte Geldgeber damit Kiev
überhaupt seine Beamten bezahlen kann
wie geht das
weiter absolut der amerikanische
Präsident wollte eigentlich mit dem
neuen Haushalt ein großes Paket in dem
sowohl Militärhilfe als auch zivile
Hilfe für die Ukraine enthalten war
durchbringen das steht jetzt in den
Sternen aber die ukrainehilfe die schon
genehmigt ist reicht noch für die
nächsten Monate man hat nämlich durch
einen Rechenfehler festgestellt dass
offenbar noch 5,5 Milliarden Dollar da
sind das heißt bis zum Jahresende wäre
auch die militärische Unterstützung für
die Ukraine gesichert aber das bedeutet
nicht dass eben bis dahin tatsächlich
eine Lösung gefunden worden ist weil man
muss bis zum 17 November einen Haushalt
für das nächste Jahr verabschieden und
nur dann könnten auch neue ukrainehilf
darüber hinaus beschlossen werden also
angesichts dieser dieser politischen
Entwicklung da muss den Europäern den
der EU ja beim Blick nach Washington
eigentlich auch mulmig
werden absolut das ist so man kriegt im
Grund ein Vorgeschmack für die geringe
Verlässlichkeit so sage ich das mal
vorsichtig die ein erwartet wenn die
trumpisten nachher nach einer Wahl im
nächsten Jahr im November eine wichtige
Rolle spielen vielleicht sogar das Weiße
Haus wieder besetzen also selbst wenn
dann tatsächlich zu s agen gemacht
werden innerhalb von Bündnissen
beispielsweise wie schnell kann das
wieder umgekippt werden wenn man so
einfach vielleicht auch hier die
Anführer jeweils stürzen könnte und
deswegen wäre interessant zu sehen ob
die acht Radikalen die zum Sturz von
mccafi geführt haben tatsächlich auch
diese macht diesen Hebel weiter in der
Hand halten können für den nächsten
Sprecher des Abgeordneten Hauses danke
schön Elma für die Analyse danke nach
washingon wenn die USA ganz ausfallen
würden etwa nach einem
präsidentenwechsel dann wäre die Ukraine
wohl verloren darauf setzt Putin ja auch
so wie er auf die Destabilisierung der
europäischen Demokratien setzt und auf
Konflikte zwischen den europäischen
Staaten dazu gehören auch die
Fluchtbewegungen aus Syrien und der
Ukraine und wenn demnächst noch ein
neuer Balkankrieg dazu käme würde man
das in Moskau auch sehr gerne sehen die
Europäer tun sich sichtlich schwer auf
diese Herausforderungen gemeinsam und
geschlossen zu reagieren mit Müh und Not
haben sie sich heute auf eine
Verschärfung in der Asylpolitik geeinigt
das Thema wird auch am Freitag beim
EU-Gipfel in Granada wieder eine
zentrale Rolle spielen mit den
altbekannten Konflikten und Akteuren
Wulf raller
berichtet Auftritt Ungarns
Regierungschef Viktor Orban Auftritt
eines Mannes der sich im Widerstand
befindet gegen die EU gegen Deutschland
gegen die Migration
seine Propaganda Videos nationalistisch
eine Invasion der Flüchtlinge bedrohe
Ungarn Orbans Botschaft wir Schotten uns
ab egal was die EU
entscheidet wir halten uns nicht an die
Vereinbarungen von
Brüssel sein Partner im Geiste der
polnische Regierungschef moraveti in
seinen wahlvideos stempelt er
Deutschland und die EU zu Versagern auch
Polen verabschiedet sich aus der
europäischen
Solidarität wir sehen diesen neuen
nationalpopulismus eigentlich in ganz
vielen Mitgliedstaaten und das ist
deswegen eine fundamentale Gefahr für
die europäische Integration für die
europäische Idee weil es eben die
gesamte Grundlage in Frage stellt der
Gipfel in Spanien soll ein Zeichen der
Geschlossenheit senden die EU sucht mit
Nachdruck nach einer Lösung zur
Migration entscheidend dabei dass alle
mitmachen und Flüchtlinge aufnehmen
Orban und moravjetki erklären bereits
jetzt einen möglichen EU Asylkompromiss
nicht zu befolgen die EU droht dann
beide Länder mit Geldstrafen zu
belegen das geht leider auf Kosten der
Menschen in diesen zwei Ländern aber Sie
müssen auch wissen glaube ich in diesen
Ländern dass wenn ihre Regierung
antieuropäisch funktioniert dass das
Konsequenzen das zweite krisenthema die
Unterstützung der Ukraine war schon
öfter der Star auf den Gipfel der
Beitritt in die EU wird ihm versprochen
aber konkrete Zusagen hat selenski nicht
bekommen er hofft auf diesen Gipfel in
Spanien auf mehr Hilfe militärisch und
finanziell aber auch hier organisieren
Ungarn und Polen ihren Widerstand Orban
und morwietki stellen die
Waffenlieferungen an die Ukraine immer
lauter in
fragen nicht länger Waffen in die
Ukraine weil wir uns selbst bewaffnen
müssen wir die lassen wir die Werte der
Europäischen Union mitfallen ab nächsten
Sommer haben erst Ungarn und dann Polen
den Ratsvorsitz in der EU beide Länder
stellen europäisches Recht immer wieder
in Frage und nun sollen sie Europa
führen ein
Problem es werden Gerichtsurteile des
Europäischen Gerichtshofs nicht
umgesetzt und jetzt einfach
weiterzumachen als würde man nicht sehen
und dem Autokraten quasi den Chefsessel
der Europäischen Union zu überlassen
halte ich für eine schlechte Idee ein
Gipfel in unsicheren Zeiten Europas
Gegner registrieren die Krisen und den
Streit in der EU sehr
genau in Granada soll es auch um den
Bergkarabach Konflikt gehen die
Aussichten dass da viel erreicht werden
scheint aber nicht besonders hoch Heinz
ja zu einem von der EU erhofften
Vermittlung Gespräch mit dem
aserbeidschanischen Präsidenten aliev
und Armeniens Regierungschef pashinan
wird es voraussichtlich nicht kommen
aliev will nach Agenturberichten nicht
zu dem Treffen kommen mit der Begründung
einer antiaserbaidschanischen Stimmung
der übrigen Gipfelteilnehmer Armeniens
Regierungschef paginan hat dennoch
angekündigt dass er anreisen
wird der AFD Vorsitzende kropalla ist
während einer Wahlkampfveranstaltung in
Ingolstadt ins Krankenhaus eingeliefert
worden nach Angaben der Partei hat es
einen tätlichen Vorfall gegen ihn
gegeben die Polizei vor Ort bestätigte
lediglich Ermittlungen was genau
vorgefallen ist ist noch
unklar Bundesgesundheitsminister
Lauterbach hat seine Pläne für eine
Neuordnung der Gesundheitsbehörden
vorgestellt demnach soll sich eine bis
2025 neu geschaffene Bundesbehörde um
verstärkte Informationen und Vorbeugung
etwa zu Krebs Demenz und
herzkreislauferkrankung kümmer
gleichzeitig soll sich das Robert Koch
Institut künftig noch klarer auf die
Abwehr von Infektionskrankheiten
konzentrieren und spezialisieren zum
neuen Präsidenten des RKI wurde Lars
schade berufen der das Amt bereits
kommissarisch geführt
hatte bei dem schweren Busunglück
gestern Abend in Venedig sind laut
italienischen Medienberichten drei
deutsche Staatsangehörige ums Leben
gekommen unterdessen hat die
Staatsanwaltschaft die Ermittlungen
übernommen geklärt werden soll warum der
Bus bei der Fahrt aus der Lagunenstadt
zurück aufs Festland von einer Brücke
etwa 15 m in die Tiefe stürzte und
danach in Flammen aufging bei dem
Unglück kamen insgesamt 21 Menschen ums
Leben für ihre Kritik am Krieg gegen die
Ukraine ist die russische tvjournalistin
Marina ofsinjankova zu 188halb Jahren
Straflager verurteilt worden ein Gericht
in Moskau befand sie in Abwesenheit der
Verbreitung von Falschinformationen über
die russische Armee
schuldiganikova hatte kurz nach
Kriegsbeginn mit einer Protestaktion im
russischen Staatsfernsehen für
internationales Aufsehen gesorgt vor
rund einem Jahr floh sie ins europäische
Ausland in Rom hat die weltsynode zur
Zukunft der katholischen Kirche begonnen
bereits bei der Eröffnungsmesse vor
55000 Gläubigen dämpfte Papst franziskus
Hoffnungen auf konkrete Reformen es gehe
nicht um Strategien und ideologische
Kämpfe der einladende Blick Jesu müsse
im Mittelpunkt stehen bis Ende Oktober
beraten 365 ausgewählte Teilnehmer
erstmals dürfen auch 54 Frauen mit
abstimmen die Selbstverständlichkeit mit
der fahrende oder parkende Autos Platz
im öffentlichen Raum einnehmen wird ja
schon länger in Frage gestellt dabei
geht es nicht nur um Klimaschutz oder
Feinstaub sondern tatsächlich auch um
territoriale Verteilungsfragen wenn man
so will wem gehört die Stadt die
Konflikte die damit einhergehen sind
erheblich in Berlin beispielsweise
konnte man beim letzten
Landtagswahlkampf den Eindruck haben die
Metropole habe keine größeren Sorgen als
die Frage ob die Friedrichstraße zur
Fußgängerzone wird insofern wird man aus
vielen deutschen Städten mit Interesse
nach Hannover blicken ob und wie es
Hannovers Oberbürgermeister sein
Wahlkampfversprechen umzusetzen was da
geplant ist berichtet
minau Hannovers Innenstadt soll nahe zuu
autofrei werden ab 2030 dürfen Autos nur
noch in Ausnahmefällen in der City
fahren so will es das neue Konzept das
eine Verkehrswende einleiten soll die
viel befahrenen Straßen werden zu
Flaniermeilen Hannover geht zu Fuß und
radelt und will mehr Platz für
Menschen ja damit setzt Hannover
wirklich Akzente und wird damit eine
Politik einleiten die alle anderen
Städte in Europa auch in Deutschland
auch verfolgen werden denn wir brauchen
eine Neuerfindung der Innenstädte doch
das ambitionierte Verkehrskonzept des
grünen Oberbürgermeisters belit onai
stößt auf Lob und Kritik bei einer
Bürgerversammlung mehr als 800
Hannoveraner sind gekommen zur
öffentlichen Präsentation die Bürger
sind teils euphorisch teils skeptisch
machen sie die Altstadt komplett zu oder
was passiert wer hier irgendwas
erreichen will in der Innenstadt der
sollte besser nicht mit dem Auto kommen
da kommt auch mal ein Drucker und
Monitor großer PC diese Schlepperei von
den Parkhäusern ist eine Katastrophe das
machen die Kunden nicht eine Stadt soll
autofrei werden indem die Autofahrer
schon jetzt um jeden Zentimeter
Parkplatz Ringen in einem Land in dem
die Zulassungszahlen für neue Pkw auch
noch steigen ein erster Schritt ist
getan doch das Konzept muss noch durch
den R
wir stehen eben vor großen
Herausforderung der Klimawandel ist in
soen Städten auch in Hannover deutlich
spürbar wir merken in der Innenstadt der
einzelandel ist Unterdruck durch
onlineehandel durch Corona und das heißt
für uns wir müssen unsere Innenstadt
zukunftsfähig aufstellen das ist das
Herz unserer Stadt die Menschen sollen h
sein sollen sich wohlfühlen und das er
ihm auch in Zukunft das Konzept soll
eine Zeitenwende sein damals sprach man
vom Wunder von Hannover als Stadt
Baudirektor Rudolf Hillebrecht nach dem
Zweiten Weltkrieg die City autogerecht
gestaltete mit breiten Straßen und einem
sechsspurigen Cityring künftig soll die
Stadt so aussehen innerhalb des Rings
werden die meisten Straßen gesperrt
Maximaltempo 20 geparkt werden darf nur
noch in Parkhäusern Händler und Anwohner
kritisieren den neuen verkehrskurs das
Schlimmste wäre halt einfach wirklich
dass die Frequenzen signifikant
zurückgehen dass die Leute einfach nicht
mehr in die Stadt kommen weil ihnen
sozusagen ja das in den Kopf ist nach
Hannover kann man nicht fahren weil die
Straßen gesperrt sind dabei liegen
verkehrsfreie Stätte gerade im Trend
weil die Aufenthaltsqualität größer wird
wenn die Autos verschwinden
argumentieren mobilitätsexperten wir
haben spektakuläre Beispiele jetzt in
Belgien in Gent in Antwerpen in Brüssel
wir haben viel von Paris gehört da wird
es noch weitergehen Kopenhagen wird
immer wieder genannt Wien und selbst die
nordamerikanischen Städten wie New York
beginnen mit dem Auto anders umzugehen
das heißt mehr Platz für andere Dinge
einzuräumen in keiner anderen deutschen
Stadt lässt sich das Ringen um die
mobilitätswende so gut beobacht
wie derzeit in
Hannover wir bleiben noch bei
Stadtpolitik das große städtische
Bahnhöfe in zentraler Lage Kriminalität
Drogenhandel und Bettelei anziehen ist
kein neues Phänomen auch die sogenannten
Rotlichtviertel lagen und liegen in
vielen Städten ja in der Nähe von
Bahnhöfen oder Seehäfen eben da wo viele
Menschen unterwegs sind wo man leicht
hinkommt und sich verabreden kann und es
überdachte öffentliche Räume gibt ob
Dortmund oder Nürnberg ob Köln oder
Hamburg Bahnhöfe und Bahnhofsviertel
sind vielerorts
problememzonen besonders offensichtlich
ist das allerdings in Frankfurt am Main
wer per Zug in Deutschlands
Finanzmetropole reist kann nach dem
Ausstieg im Hauptbahnhof erstmal einen
Schock erleben Stefan Schlösser
berichtet wieder greift die Polizei
durch kommt von allen Seiten riegelt
eine Straße komplett ab rund 200 Beamte
sind im Einsatz es ist bereits die
dritte große ratiia innerhalb weniger
Wochen im Frankfurter bahnhofsfettel
dutzende Personen werden festgesetzt
kontrolliert Drogen sichergestellt wir
hatten eine Kriminalitätsentwicklung im
Spätsommer letzten Jahres die uns auch
ein bisschen Sorge bereitet hat wir
habten massiven Anstieg im Bereich
raubdelekt Taschen und rckdienstelle
hier im Bereich des bahnhofsgebietes
haben darauf mit einer deutlichen
Erhöhung der polizeilichen Präsenz jeden
Tag reagiert und flankieren zu dieser
Erhöhung der Präsenz machen wir auch äh
Anlass unabhängig immer mal wieder
solche großkontrollen gemeinsam mit der
Bereitschaftspolizei zusammen Rotlicht
Viertel Partymeile drogenhotspot in
Frankfurt prallen die Milieus
aufeinander das Elend der abhängigen ist
offen im Straßenbild sichtbar war es
früher Heroin dominiert heute Crack es
macht die Menschen schneller physisch
und psychisch kaputt Wolfgang Bart ist
seit 40 Jahren in der Drogenhilfe aktiv
leitet den drogennotdienst hier können
sich abhängige unter sauberen
Bedingungen Heroin Spritzen wir müssen
uns aber auch darauf einstellen dass
andere konsummuste dazu geführt haben
dass Personen ein anderes Verhalten
zeigen die wir mit den bestehenden
Hilfeangeboten nicht erreichen können
und damit meine ich das Thema kreck die
zusehens schlechtere Situation im
bahnhofsfittel ist ein Politikum das
Land unterstützt mit vielen
Polizeikräften sieht aber vor allem die
Stadt in der
Pflicht aus meiner Sicht ist jetzt eben
auch die Stadt Frankfurt am Zuge
beispielsweise durch die Ausweitung
einer waffenverbotszone und eben auch
durch eine Ausweitung der
Videoüberwachung aber auch durch mehr
Sauberkeit im Bahnhofsviertel ich biete
der Stadt Frankfurt gerne die
Partnerschaft mit dem Land Hessen an
dass wir das gemeinsam schultern können
in Wiesbaden gibt es seit über vier
Jahren eine waffenverbotszone die
Ergebnisse durchaus positiv klar aber
auch mehr Polizei allein kann es nicht
richten es geht nur miteinander und das
muss konsequent auf ausgebaut werden die
nächste Hilfseinrichtung ist in karlsruh
im Süden oder wenn ich Richtung
Nordwesten gehe in Köln oder Bonn und
hier fordern wir natürlich ein breiteres
Angebot damit Frankfurt nicht zum
drogentourismusplatz Nummer 1 in
Deutschland weiterhin verkommt der
Magistrat der stadtgät zunehmend unter
Druck eine waffenverbotzone ist in der
mehr parteienkoalition kein Konsens
stattdessen gibt es erst einmal Geld zum
Interview vor der Kamera ist der
Oberbürgermeister nicht bereit
schriftlich heißt es zuletzt hat die
Regierungskoalition im Römer ein 5
Millionen Euro schweres Sofortprogramm
für das Bahnhofsviertel an den stat
gebracht es erweitert deutlich die
bestehenden Hilfsangebote für
drogenkranke Menschen bei der Razia
werden acht Personen wegen Drogenhandels
festgenommen 20 Ermittlungsverfahren
eingeleitet Polizeipräsenz Hilfsangebote
Belebung des Viertels im Grunde sind
sich alle einig dass etwas geschehen
muss man fragt sich nur warum es dann
nicht endlich
passiert und mit einem anderen
sozialpolitischen Thema geht's bei dir
jetzt noch mal weiter zu den erklärten
Zielen der Bundesregierung gehört der
Bau von rund 100.000 Sozialwohnungen pro
Jahr im vergangenen Jahr waren es
deutlich weniger und aktuell machen
höhere Kosten und gestiegene Zinsen den
Bau zu schaffen werie Haller wie ist
also der Stand der Dinge beim sozialen
Wohnungsbau ja er ist schon seit Jahren
nicht gut durch die aktuell schwierige
Lage am Immobilienmarkt aber hat sie
sich noch mal verschärft Projekte werden
auf Eis gelegt oder gar nicht erst
geplant weil es sich oft eben nicht mehr
rechnet das betrifft natürlich auch
Sozialwohnungen deren Bestand ist sogar
rückläufig und das deutschlandweit
während es vor 10 Jahren noch mehr als
eineinhalb Millionen Sozialwohnungen gab
sind es heute nur noch etwas mehr als
eine Million Grund nach einer
festgelegten Zeit fallen die Wohnungen
aus der Sozialbindung gehen in den
freien Markt über und werden meist
deutlich teurer vermietet neue
Sozialwohnungen aber kommen kaum nach
von dem von der Regierung angepeilten
100.000 Sozialwohnungen pro Jahr wurden
2022 lediglich rund
22500 gebaut damit Sankt die Zahl der
Sozialwohnungen erneut denn mehr als 36
000 felen Weg gleichzeitig ist der
Bedarf hoch
mal höher als der bestand laut
Mieterbund die Regierung will
gegensteuern Unternehmen die dauerhaft
günstige Mieten anbieten sollen
Unterstützung bekommen steuerlich oder
durch Investitionszulagen doch viele
Fragen sind noch offen größ Knackpunkt
wie viel die Ampel dafür ausgeben möchte
Valerie Haller vielen
dank neuer EU klimakommissar soll der
niederländische Christdemokrat hüchstra
werden er bekam im Umweltausschuss des
europarlaments seine zwei Drittel
Mehrheit nach einer stundenlangen
Befragung hatten die Abgeordneten ihre
Entscheidung zunächst verschoben
bedenken gab es wegen höchstris
beruflicher Vergangenheit in einem
Ölkonzern morgen muss noch das gesamte
EU-Parlament zustimmen
der Nobelpreis für Chemie geht in diesem
Jahr an drei in den USA tätige Forscher
munge bwendi Luis Bruce und Alexi imov
werden für die Entdeckung und
Entwicklung von sogenannten
Quantenpunkten geehrt die winzigen
Teilchen gibt es in vielen
elektronischen Geräten wie etwa LED
Fernsehern und auch in der Krebsmedizin
kommen sie zum Einsatz durch eine Panne
waren die Namen der preisträge bereits
Stunden vor der offiziellen bekannt an
die Öffentlichkeit
gelangt die Fußballweltmeisterschaft
2030 soll mit Spielen in sechs Ländern
auf drei Kontinenten stattfinden in
Europa sind es Spanien und Portugal in
Afrika Marokko und in Südamerika Uruguay
Argentinien und Paraguay mit dieser
Vergabe wolle man so der
Fußballweltverband den 100 geburtstag
der Fußball WM global und einzigartig
feiern und jetzt die die Zahlen vom
Lotto am Mittwoch sie lauten wie immer
ohne Gewehr 18 19 28 38 43 46 Superzahl
9 und weitere gewinnzahen finden Sie auf
lotto.zfde und im ZF Text auf Seite
557 das war's von uns gleich folgt das
auslandjournal mit einer besonderen
Ausgabe die Sendung feiert ihren 50
Geburtstag Anlass für eine kleine
Zeitreise durch fün Jahrzehnte
Auslandsberichterstattung und um 045 uh
meldet sich nasan göckt mir mit unserem
heute Schal Update wir sind dann morgen
wieder da bis dahin
[Musik]
Wiedersehen schön guten Abend und
herzlich willkommen zum Wetter
größtenteils Herr er Luftdruck von
Spanien bis nach Deutschland aber diese
Kaltfront hier die über den Norden zieht
bringt durchaus auch kräftigen Regen mit
und wie geht's weiter in den nächsten
Tagen macht sich eine neue warmluftblase
auf dem Weg hier ist der Atlantik noch
recht warm da kommt die warme Luft und
auch vom Festland her Richtung
Mitteleuropa und das bedeutet es sind
tatsächlich wieder 30° drin in der
kommenden Nacht haben wir es aber mit
der Kaltfront zu tun ganz im Norden
Regen teils Gewitter und dazu kräftiger
Südwestwind kann durchaus stürmisch sein
nach Süden hin gibt's Nebel hier ist es
richtig ruhig Temperaturen gehen zurück
dort auf 3 bis 4° sonst ist es deutlich
milder an der Nordsee mit 14° und morgen
gibt's vor allem nach Norden Regen und
der lässt im Tagesverlauf nach der Wind
ist weiterhin kräftig aus westlichen
Richtungen im Süden da sind die Wolken
aufgelockert und die Sonne zeigt sich
häufiger die höchsten Temperaturen
liegen bei 16° z.B in der Eifel und 21°
im Südwesten das ist die
temperaturpanne insgesamt liegen wir im
normalen Bereich mit den Werten und die
nächsten Tage ja am Freitag gibt's ganz
im Norden Regen ansonsten ganz im Süden
Nebel dazwischen auch sonnige Abschnitte
bei 17 bis 23° am Samstag 26 und Sonntag
sogar bis
28° und damit einen schönen Abend